made a statement at the beginning um
about where the organization stood i
would say the legal it's it's a legal
situation it's a legal process so we're
certainly respectful of that uh we
certainly take them very seriously uh
the allegations um are what's been
discussed or certainly troubling um and
organizationally that's not something
that that we can condone that we we
condone those types of actions but again
we'll let the legal process take care of
itself and however it's going to unfold
we'll certainly comply and do what we
can to help and facilitate a resolution
for everybody
that's texans gm nick casario from the
texans podcast the only thing the team
has said other than the perfunctory
written statement that came out in the
immediate aftermath of the commencement
of one lawsuit after another against
deshaun watson alleging misconduct
during massages
separate from the litigation chris an
anonymous woman who was vetted by jenny
verentis of si.com yeah right
has her own version that corroborates
this notion that there was unusual
behavior during a massage
his conduct was unlike anything she's
ever experienced from any other client
she's treated great story from jenny at
si.com this woman who goes by the
pseudonym mary
contacted the tony busby law firm he's
the lawyer who represents
all of the plaintiffs who have filed
suit so far she declined to sign with
busby she felt like she was being
pressured by busby's firm she's talking
to another lawyer about what her options
are may sue may not sue
regardless of whether she does or
doesn't there are now chris 19 19 of
these lawsuits and presumably counting
because busby has claimed at least 20
have been filed and there could be as
many as 24. so this is something
that continues we continue to address it
because it continues to generate news
when it doesn't generate news we don't
address it when it does we have to yeah
i mean again i mean not not good not
good and i i mean like i don't know how
you feel but i mean really it's like
it's stories like that on si.com
that i think are some of the most
damning like that when the fact where
it's like yes there's no legal counsel
she's not a decide to sue she's just
sharing her story to go no this is
messed up like this is what happened
that to me is is you know the worst look
in a lot of ways i know all of it's a
bad look but
again it just doesn't seem like you know
there's a motive there right now
rather than just going wait this guy's
got a history and that that's where it's
not good uh so this this thing is
unbelievable i still can't believe uh
it's happening
and
i just don't know where it goes now like
mike i mean
i i i think we're past the like i i know
i talked to somebody in the league right
over the weekend like you know i have a
hard time thinking any trade goes down
at any point any time soon right it's
not happening not happening right crazy
okay be crazy for anyone to take on
desean watson now via trade
given so much that needs to be resolved
and no indication
that it's going to be resolved anytime
soon chris you know my position get
everybody in a room get a retired judge
there work everything out to the
satisfaction of all involved i'm not
saying buy this off quickly and quietly
and make it make it go away i'm saying
give everyone involved the feeling
they're having a day in court give
everyone involved who's making a
complaint against watson a sense of
satisfaction if it's not about money
what's it about the problem is it is
about money and and because
there is a clear incentive for watson to
put this behind him quickly so he can
get on with his career
i think that
is going to make it much more expensive
because again the whole system is
premised on money folks tony busby can
say whatever he wants the civil justice
system is premised on money and there's
a business component to this if you
think one side wants to resolve the case
that makes what the other side wants
even more because they know they know
that it's in deshaun watson's interest
to make this all go away and again i
don't mean make it go away quietly i
mean end it well so i mean at what point
would busby entertain that right i mean
he seems steadfast on going to court i
mean is that the type of thing i mean
again i'm just spitballing here that
like watson just has to make a big offer
and then we see where it goes how does
you know that's where i'm i i'm just i
still think yeah pressure him to bring
everyone into the room pressure him
publicly privately however bring your
clients to a mediation and let's deal
with these cases one at a time and let's
try to resolve them to the satisfaction
not of tony busby but to the
satisfaction of each of his clients
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports